dan Vaughn Gino is a former Secret
Service agent he's an NRI TV contributor
and he joins us tonight so a lot of
people are saying Dan as you know you
know why should here you have this kid
who was nineteen he was a nut case
shouldn't have had a gun in the first
place yet he bought it legally so maybe
we should ban all people his age or
under 21 from buying guns what'd you say
I say I'm really sick of liberals I mean
like really sick like getting physically
ill listening to them because they can't
be consistent on an argument you know
what's fascinating about your prior
guests I've argued with liberals about
so-called gun control which you
accurately called people control you're
right for days now and they'll make
opposing arguments just a few days ago a
guy said to me well you know you have to
be 21 to buy alcohol
I said you're talking about a the
purchase of a mind-altering substance
not the operation of a firearm yet this
guy comes around and talking about
voting he makes the exact opposite
argument well they're apples and oranges
so is booze and guns but it doesn't
matter to liberals because they'll tell
you the same thing Tucker about
immigration laws and abortion laws
they'll be like you know what those laws
don't matter immigration we don't really
have to follow those laws matter of fact
people don't and we should give them
government benefits abortion laws don't
put any abortion laws on the books
they'll all be ignored but gun laws
those all really work those will
definitely stop homicidal maniacs from
getting guns and preying on the rest of
us while we're all unarmed this is so
beyond stupid that we're all losing IQ
points by debating with these people
well I think that's right i mean
abortions would just not mention the
constitution is the beating heart of our
constitutional rights whereas guns which
are in the second amendment in the Bill
of Rights oh that's not even there so I
guess I appreciate people who are
sincerely trying to solve this problem
because all of us recognize how horrible
it is but are you starting to suspect
that a lot of these so-called solutions
are not really about making the public
safer but about something else
Tucker 15 years in law enforcement in
five years studying the issue and doing
commentary on it this is what people
have to understand get this through your
heads and don't ever forget it there
were two parallel tracks for gun owners
okay for liberals let's do this slow
here's one here's two okay on the first
track you have League
gun owners you have to go through a
background check fill out a 4473 you
can't be a prohibited possessor okay
that's how good people non criminals get
guns then you have track number two
people who steal them and buy them on
the black market they don't care about
track number one Tucker at all so you
have a law by the way which only impacts
good law-abiding people and does nothing
for criminals let me ask you this Tucker
what other law works like that the
burglary laws effect you have a sense
Tucker Carlson ever thought about
burglarizing a house and be like darn
that they don't affect the burglary laws
you don't care about at all you're like
good
let's have maximum penalties for
burglary laws gun laws are the only laws
that affect the law-abiding and don't
effect criminals one bit they have a
thriving black market for guns I mean
it's absurd our immigration laws keep
out millions of potential software
engineers but are ignored by 11 million
people from the third world to living
everything they didn't care right no
it's a perfect it's a perfect example
dan thank you for that I appreciate it
yes sir